nisrine et bars 13 ans l'étoile montante
du taekwondo en france la sportive qui
s'entraînent quatre fois par semaine au
club de trappes a décroché le 14 mai
dernier à lyon le titre de championne de
france dans la catégorie cadette moins
de 47 kg il m'a dit que je voulais
gagner que j allais cette fois c'est
pour gagner pas pour perdre et et vous
les premières ce titre n'est pas une
surprise pour les dirigeants et coach du
club qui l'ont vu évoluer pendant six
ans dans la structure pour être honnête
on on l'a mise est sûre elle vous pensez
vraiment que vous pouvez arriver
jusqu'au bout être championne de france
dans lequel cuando plus on les grands et
fin donc automatiquement la de la longe
et assez bien s'en servir
allez assez doué techniquement elle a
des bonnes techniques assez écoutée elle
lâche pas la faire à la détermination à
va jusqu'au bout de ce qu'elle fait
cette victoire lui a permis de décrocher
une sélection en équipe de france pour
le prochain championnat d'europe qui se
tiendra en septembre à bucarest en
roumanie suis très content très fier de
moi je voulais un jour à altérer à
l'équipe de france est massé réaliser
j'ai travaillé dur pour arriver à ça à
pouvoir aller dans l'équipe de france et
l'équipe de france prochaine étape pour
la jeune trappistes un titre de
championne d'europe avant d'essayer
d'atteindre son rêve une qualification
pour les jeux olympiques 2024